feel like if you're not like mentally
like
strong enough it can really break you no
but for me like compared to getting 100k
getting a million just for some reason
didn't feel as good yeah
no i don't know definitely not i just
felt like it ticked over you know yeah
yeah it's like when like your car hit
like a hundred thousand miles like yeah
and it's just like i feel like mental
health and just taking care of your
mental health is like such an important
thing
to to to think about when when you're
becoming a youtuber and nobody really
thinks about that when they
say oh yeah i want to be a youtuber like
you've certainly got a great thick skin
i mean i do
read most of my comments on my videos i
feel like no say
when i make a video it's like hosting a
party and you want to be there for the
party you don't just make a video and
then [ __ ] off you want to actually be
there for the house party mingle with
the guests
and then go to sleep at 4am and i
love that i love that uh but if you do
read the comments they'll always be the
ones that are like oh you're fat now
your comments are [ __ ] brutal like
someone said you look like a [ __ ]
elon musk
those are funny though it's the ones
where they do like just the littlest
jab really gets you yeah yeah well they
might have said something about that one
thing in the video you were insecure
about
yeah and it just ruins you you're like
[ __ ] my whole day is ruined because of
that one comment you just hit the right
thing
i mean i got my fair share of that when
i was on your journey across japan
i think you always get it when as a new
person on the channel like a few guests
got that it wasn't just you
on jen across japan joey like uh my good
friend pete you want to do the podcast
yeah
he got that as well because his new
guest is very different
and right right you always gonna get
that i think i mean how do you guys deal
with hate comments
or like i don't i feel like as a
youtuber
the what what a normal person would
consider hate and what a youtuber would
cons you have to really push that
that goal to like like yeah because you
if you consider even the slightest thing
hey you're gonna yeah
right that's the thing right it's like
it's like it depends like it depends on
what they say right
if it's something like very like
opinionated like
i just don't like so and so because i
just don't yeah and it's like
you can't really do anything about it
because that's just their opinion yeah
yeah but when it's like
really persistent and really petty
that's when you're like
okay like what's what's your issue i
find some of those funny
it's like i said earlier the ones where
they do find that one thing you're
worried about the specific thing
you somehow feel like they they know
what you're insecure about
there's that one thing like you you can
have like the worst hate comment in the
world and it's like some
like sometimes like a one sentence
comment just like
bothers you for the entire day
i've had comments like you're an [ __ ]
i'm like that's funny yeah
but then they'll just like that i
comment what it was that's i read one
recently i was like [ __ ] you you got me
i hate you so much that was it so what
are you my therapist
yeah like that right they just hit you
in like where you were like you were
insecure about it and you're like god
damn it like they got it
but you you you just kind of learn like
all right yeah that sucks but
i've got to deal with it right if i let
it affect the videos then you know
yeah i mean that's what i'm doing right
i feel like the craze that phase is over
but hate mail reading comment
you know reading those videos yeah that
was really fun i feel like you can't
really do it anymore i feel like it
happened like three years ago
yeah yeah i did i did one like three
years ago
i've done three videos and wrote that
wave and viewers always loved it you
know because the comments i used to get
which is ridiculous like i hate
british men that speaks with the mouth
like pitbull
and because in the uk we have [ __ ]
which are like meatballs right yeah yeah
i like meatball oh right yeah north
america
yeah yeah yeah yeah that word always
drove me up the wall um
but yeah it's just yeah because i i feel
like you adapt right you adapt you learn
i mean it kind of sucks because like as
anyone like any influencer i gotta hate
using that word but like dirty word
oh the words i don't want to be
associated with me but still is
associated with the second
least favorite word next to content
creator for like like
a lot of questions i get from like other
smaller creators like how would you deal
with hate comments how
how did you not let that affect you and
i think it [ __ ] sucks that all you
can say is
you get used to it and that that's not
that's not a solution that's a [ __ ]
coping mechanism
you know what i mean part of the job
yeah yeah do you remember when when you
started uploading first and you got that
first dislike
and you were like who [ __ ] did this
what who disliked this
how and then yeah now you should accept
that for some reason you'll have a
thousand and you're not really sure why
you have a thousand but you're like
that's normal
i expect a thousand and then when you
don't when you don't get it but when you
think about it
like when you think about a thousand
people surrounding you who just [ __ ]
dislike yeah yeah just like oh
okay it's weird but i remember there
would be like i had a friend who and
they started out they had like a mental
breakdown when they got a dislike
they're like who disliked it no one in
the comments said they disliked it who
did this why did they do it
and it's like it's like you just got to
deal with it
i'm sorry man no because like
um i i remember one of the hardest
lessons i had to learn
was just learning that you can't please
out of everyone
yeah and they're especially like i
remember a point when it seemed like
every
everyone everyone was positive about
what you were doing you know
you didn't really get yeah yeah and then
you start
you you reach this point when people
just start hating you like as a person
or maybe
like they personally dislike your
personality or something about you and
you're like
i don't know why you dislike me i've
never met you i've never seen you
but you seem to dislike me and i'm just
like having to learn that
there are just going to be people that
dislike you is like one of the hardest
things i've had to learn it's it's still
a thing i think uh
i still like have to like come to terms
with like you'd like some people just
kind of dislike you
yeah and it sucks you have to accept
that right i feel especially when like
you know when
again like because the large majority of
youtube is american
and i don't want to say like americans
don't get sarcasm but
a lot of them don't and unfortunately
all four of us are very well versed
any form of jokes right it could fall
flat and to that person
i think yeah